[Applaudissements]
et si on se réveillait dans un monde 120
imaginer plus de champagne pour vos
célébrations
plus de 20 pour accompagner vos petits
plats
plus de paysages viticoles plus de route
des vins pour se promener
14 milliards d'euros qui disparaissent
d'un seul coup à peu près 3% des
exportations nationales
et puis surtout le pire de tous nos tire
bouchon qui sont relégués dans les
musées
bon fort heureusement évidemment vous en
doutez on n'en est pas là on n'est pas
là mais comme tous les systèmes
agricoles du monde et tous les
écosystèmes de la planète bien
évidemment le monde du vin et toucher de
plus en plus par l'évolution du climat
alors
ce sont des orages de grêle violent
c'est du gel tardif ce sont des épisodes
de chaleur intense de la canicule de la
sécheresse qui sont de plus en plus
fréquent est de plus en plus violents
sur l'ensemble de nos terroirs et sur
l'ensemble de nos vignobles mais c'est
aussi des maladies émergentes qui
arrivent discrètement mais sûrement
et puis également
ce sont sur l'ensemble de nos
territoires
une évolution de la maturité du raisin
avec notamment plus d'alcool dans les
vins et donc derrière des produits qui
sont beaucoup moins agréable à déguster
alors certes ce n'est pas de la science
fiction
certes le programme est préoccupant mais
une bonne nouvelle pour vous
il ya de l'espoir il ya de l'espoir et
l'espoir il est là
c'est un sarment de vigne en
l'occurrence un char donner aux
champenois
alors il elle est là la solution parce
que ce que j'ai en main ici c'est tout à
la fois une espèce en danger
mais en même temps une partie de la
solution pourquoi parce que la vigne est
une plante pérenne 1 un sarment de vigne
comme ça ça peut vivre 50 ans entend
peut-être même parfois plus dans
certaines régions donc ça s'inscrit dans
le temps long et à partir du moment où
ça se construit dans le temps long ça
veut dire que réfléchir à l'adaptation
de nos vignobles à l'évolution
climatique c'est plus généralement
réfléchir à comment donner plus de
résilience à l'ensemble de nos
écosystèmes
sort pour comprendre
je vais vous demander de faire un petit
retour dans l'histoire
et notamment sur les un demi siècle
d'histoire de l'agriculture moderne
je vais reprendre ma petite [ __ ]
en fait ce demi-siècle d'aller culture
moderne on courait finalement le
comparer un espèce de grand opéra dont
nous allons assister très bientôt au
grand final
l'ouverture de cet opéra c'est la
rupture du 19e siècle avec la révolution
industrielle en 1850 en france encore
trois quarts de la population est rurale
mais
également
en l'espace d'un siècle la population va
augmenter de plus de 40% est non
seulement une volonté depuis 40 % mais
en même temps elle va se délocaliser car
une bonne partie de la population rurale
va migrer vers les villes en même temps
les transports se développent les
frontières ne devienne plus des
barrières et c'est la mise en place
progressive de notre économie de marché
et avec cette école marché vient
effectivement des besoins en produits
agricoles toujours plus importants en
1876 et créer l'institut national
d'agronomie qui vient
nourrir la connaissance nécessaire pour
le monde agricole afin de construire des
systèmes agricoles de plus en plus
performants et pour tirer toujours le
muc toujours plus de parties de nos sols
acte pain mécanisation
19e siècle les engins agricoles
progresse rapidement d'abord avec la
traction animale puis la machine à
vapeur mais surtout début du 20e siècle
l'arrivée du moteur à explosion
avec lui la mise à disposition de
l'énergie du pétrole pour l'ensemble de
l'ue le monde agricole
en l'espace de 60 ans nous allons
diminuer multiplier par dix la quantité
d'énergie disponible pour un agriculteur
pour travailler sur un hectare de vigne
acte 2 les engrais
alors bien évidemment à force
d'améliorer les rendements de nos
cultures on va se rendre compte assez
rapidement que l'exportation des
nutriments du sol est beaucoup plus
rapide que notre capacité à les
régénérer
alors on va compenser on va compenser
d'abord avec des apports naturels du
lisier du guano qui va devenir un grand
business lépi là on va se dire ça suffit
toujours pas force est de constater que
ça suffit toujours pas et donc
jusqu'en 1909
où le procès des abers gauche va être
inventés par les allemands qui va nous
permettre de transformer la zone
atmosphérique en engrais minérale et la
donner accès au monde agricole a
quasiment une ressource infinie
d'azoté pour fertiliser leurs champs
acte 3 sélections variétales
toutes les plantes n'ont pas les mêmes
capacités
vous savez qu effectivement certaines
pour produire plus d'autres seront plus
résistante à certaines maladies ou
encore d'autres plus à des plus adaptés
à certaines zones climatiques donc en
sélectionnant les individus en les
croisant entre eux on va petit à petit
faire émerger les individus les plus
performants pour assurer les rendements
agricoles dont on a besoin
acte iv
les pesticides demeura parle
effectivement si on va maintenir nos
rendements agricoles on doit forcément à
limiter aussi les pertes par ailleurs et
les pertes on a des cultures elles
viennent bien souvent des agresseurs que
ce soit des maladies fongiques où les
ravageurs des insectes il faut le
stopper et là encore
la chili va venir nous aider il va nous
permettre d'inventer des produits
extrêmement redoutable pour lutter
contre l'ensemble de ses agressions et
lui je disais on est dans un grand final
de cet opéra oui le grand final il vient
doucement mais il vient à partir de la
deuxième guerre mondiale à partir de la
deuxième guerre mondiale tout s'emballe
revenons sur la population la population
repart fortement à la hausse mais sur la
courbe verte surtout vous voyez que la
population rurale elle elle diminue donc
de moins en moins de gens pour assurer
toujours plus de production
les rendements explose vous voyez
notamment en orange au centre les
rendements céréaliers is explose mais
dans le même temps sur le pointillé
rouge si vous voyez la chute
vertigineuse des surfaces agricoles
utiles donc on voit bien ici pointé les
problématiques d'intensification de la
régulation
bien évidemment pour assurer tous nos
rendements on en a parlé tout à l'heure
il faut
des fertilisants vous voyez par exemple
ici en bleu clair l'explosion de
l'utilisation des engrais industriel
azotés
et au final tout ça ça consomme de
l'énergie et donc bien évidemment les
consommations énergétiques au service de
la lecture vous aussi explosé et vous
voyez notamment aussi un shift entre ces
types d'énergie puisque à partir de la
deuxième guerre mondiale et surtout à
partir des années 60 quand vous voyez
que on va surtout vers des énergies
carbonées
que ce soit pour les carburants utilisés
dans les machines agricoles ou surtout
pour produire ces fameuses engrais
industriels
alors où en se mouvant finalement nous
avons construit une sorte de colosse aux
pieds d'argile dont la performance
agronomique n'a d'égal que sa fragilité
parce qu'il est extrêmement fragile et
pourquoi est-il aussi fragile et bien
parce que finalement on l'a emmené dans
un ensemble de cercle vicieux je vais
vous en citer trois principaux le
premier
les émissions de gaz à effet de serre
l'agriculture aujourd'hui il faut le
savoir les responsables de 19 % des
émissions co2 sur le plan national c'est
le deuxième poste d'émission de co2 sur
le plan national tant par les
destinations de mécanisation bien
évidemment que aussi parler
décarbonatation des sols
mais plus que ça
l'agriculture représente 80% des
émissions de protoxyde d'azoté qui sont
issus pour la plupart de nous faire tilt
10 ans et le protoxyde d azote c'est 300
fois plus réchauffant que le co2
303 plus
donc on est dans un système où
finalement plus on exploite nos terrains
d'école puis on a besoin d'énergie
puissant qui génère de gaz à effet de
serre qui fusillait d'impact derrière de
répercussions sur nos cultures
le deuxième cercle vicieux l'épuisement
de nos sols c'est un vrai sol en un seul
de vignes en l'occurrence que j'ai
photographié derrière chez moi en fait
on voit que comme je disais tout à
l'heure déjà on vit à crédit
donc dans nos sols on ira puiser plus
qu'on aurait introduit donc forcément au
bout d'un moment il ya un phénomène
d'épuisement qui secret mais aussi avec
la mécanisation va l'aider phénomène de
tassement seul et le tassement des sols
qu'est ce que ça fait mal ça évite par
exemple à l'eau de pouvoir pénétrer et
s'infiltrer dans les couches profondes
mais également le tassement des sols ça
va empêcher l'air et l'oxygène ne
circulait dans les couches
superficielles du sol et l'eau l'air
l'oxygène tout ça c'est très important
pour la vie des sols donc le tassement
des salaires asphyxier les seuls et ça
vient donc faire progressivement
disparaître la vie des sols mais encore
plus important que ça et vous pouvez
vous en rendre compte sur cette photo
l'érosion l'érosion de nos seuls à force
d'utiliser des herbicides à force
d'utiliser massivement le labour on
expose nos sols nus aux intempéries ce
qui les fait progressivement disparaître
et il faut se rendre compte qu'à
l'échelle mondiale
en disant vous avez l'équivalent de la
surface d'un département français qui
disparaît
hansen avec vols alors que derrière il
nous faut à peu près 100 à 200 entre
pour régénérer un seul petit centimètres
de sol
le troisième cercle vicieux c'est celui
de l'affaiblissement des plantes
parce que avec nos engrais avec nos
pesticides en fait nous avons mis nos
plantes sous perfusion
ce faisant elles perdent un certain
nombre de leurs aptitudes naturelles
c'est un peu comme nous ainsi on arrête
de marché parce qu'on est immobilisé
pour un accident votre ce soir on perd
de la masse musculaire c'est pareil pour
les plantes elle s'appelle perdre des
fonctions naturelles et par exemple la
mycorhize à sion c'est à dire cette
faculté certaines plantes roues dans la
vigne de faire des symbiose avec des
champignons du sol de manière à pouvoir
plus efficacement et plus facilement
absorber les nutriments du sol mais
aussi
l'affaiblissement des cultures c'est ça
alors il ya deux façons de voir ça soit
on se dit c'est un magnifique paysage
viticole où il fait bon se promener tout
à fait exact le confirmer mais si on
peut aussi de voir comme ça et moi en ce
moment je me vois plutôt comme ça c'est
l'armée des clones parce que nos
paysages viticoles aujourd'hui en fait
ils sont constitués de très peu
d'individus tous génétiquement
identiques et donc c'est une véritable
armée de clones alors quel est le
problème quel problème c'est que
derrière on perd la biodiversité dans
nos vignobles et qui dit perte de
diversité dit que toute attaque ou toute
épidémie qui va venir attaquer une
production agricole va se disséminer
comme un feu dans une botte de paille
alors comment on fait pour essayer de
sortir de ce cercle vicieux
il faut changer notre approche
on a tous ici moi le premier nous gérer
la communauté des chercheurs mais vous
tous dans ses salles la même habitude
c'est à dire que pour résoudre des
problèmes complexes
on passe par des approches analytiques
on imagine toujours un problème complexe
comme une espèce d'empilement de briques
on va devoir des composés pour essayer
de identifier quelle est la brique la
plus importante intervenir c'est certes
briques la plus importante dans dix ans
elle va probablement nous résoudre
l'essentiel de notre problème
par exemple j'ai une nouvelle maladie
sur un vignoble je vais essayer d'y
manie de trouver quel est le pathogène
responsable est derrière tout mettre en
oeuvre pour éradiquer ce bateau j'ai mon
problème devrait probablement
disparaître
oui mais la réalité est beaucoup plus
complexe que ça parce que la réalité du
vivant ce sont des écosystèmes
et dans écosystème il ya un système
c'est à dire que nos écosystèmes sont
composés d'objets les objets de nos
écosystèmes c'est une vie un seul un
couvert végétal des insectes des oiseaux
des paysages
mais c'est aussi et surtout des
interactions entre ces objets et ce sont
ces interactions qui sont importantes
parce que c'est souvent les interactions
qui sont déterminantes dans le
comportement du système
sauf que pour comprendre les
interactions des écosystèmes et bien
c'est extrêmement compliqué et donc il
faut plonger dans cette complexité pour
être capable de transformer le vigneron
d'aujourd'hui demain en un pilote
d'écosystèmes qui sera vraiment aux
commandes de sa culture avec une vraie
ambition durabilité alors à quoi ça
ressemble dans la réalité est bien un
système ça se comporte un peu comme un
fils et un philippin qui est tendu
ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est que dès
qu'on appuie quelque part sur le fil et
l'ensemble du filet se déforme un
écosystème c'est la même chose
il faut être capable d'embrasser la
complexité des écosystèmes pour savoir
mieux les piloter mieux les maîtriser et
mieux assurer leur durabilité et leur
résilience face au climat qui de toute
façon
changera indéniablement
alors à quoi ça ressemble sur un paysage
viticole et bien voilà vous avez ici
affaire à un certain nombre de pieds
ville d'abord ce qui va falloir faire
s'est assuré une microbiologie du sol
qui soit la plus performante et la plus
dynamique possible parce que cette
microbiologie des sols c'est elle qui va
assurer la régénération des nutriments
dans la plante a besoin pour se nourrir
ça passe par évidemment beaucoup moins
de travail des sols pour éviter de
détruire la vie dans les premiers
centimètres de sol mais aussi pour
protéger ses zones de l'érosion
évidemment éviter un maximum les
produits pesticides et autres qui
détruisent les micro-organismes et aussi
par entretenir de la biodiversité
environnantes pour qu'il ya un pool
génétique de microbes à la disposition
qui soit toujours maximiser sa passe
aussi par une faune souterraine donc les
petits insectes les petits verts et
quand on connaît tous bien parce que eux
ils sont visibles qui sont très
importants il faut entretenir cette
faune souterraine parce qu'elle fait des
galeries et en faisant des galeries elle
permet à l'eau de passer à travers le
sol elle permet d'entretenir la
structure du sol d'aérer les sols de
permettre un meilleur réchauffement des
sols etc et c'est donc très important
ça passe aussi par entretenir la
biodiversité aérienne et notamment les
oiseaux c'est que les oiseaux peuvent
avoir effectivement pas mal de rôle à
jouer dans la lutte contre les
agresseurs notamment lorsque ce sont des
insectes de la vigne mais aussi il faut
entretenir certains pollinisateurs par
exemple sont bénéfiques peut-être pas
forcément pour la vigne mais pour
d'autres cultures qu'ils soient
environnantes
tout ça est très important il faut ça
veut dire quoi cela il faut aussi
travailler à l'échelle du paysage et
celle du paysage il faut détendre des
endroits pour nicher il faut des
endroits pour se nourrir
il faut des couverts végétaux ça c'est
très important aussi encore une fois pas
de sol nu donc un converger talent pour
protéger les sols mais aussi profiter du
système racinaire de ces plantes pour
continuer à structurer les sols mais
également pour donner à ces sols une
forte capacité de réintégration de
carbone parce que les sols sont un puits
de carbone considérable on n'en parle
pas suffisamment mais
il faut à peu près si on était en
capacité d'augmenter de 0 4% par an la
capacité des sols a fixé le carbone
on serait capable de stabiliser
l'évolution du co2 dans l'atmosphère
ça vous en avez peut-être entendu parler
c'est le projet 4 pour 1000 qui a été
lancé par la france lors de la cop 21
et puis bien évidemment notre plan elle
même la vigne est une source de
biodiversité
elle a une diversité intrinsèque alors
on la connaît chez nous plutôt sous le
terme de ces pages mais les cépages y
sont nombreux et à l'intérieur de ces
cépages il ya beaucoup de diversité on
appelle ça des clones
et donc implanter plusieurs diversité de
ces pages nous de clown dans la même
parcelle contribue à entretenir une
forme de résilience dans la parcelle et
on peut faire la même chose sur le porte
greffe puisque la vigne est une plante
greffer un donc la partie aérienne et la
partie souterraine qui sont pas les
mêmes individus donc chacun en fait
honte une certaine biodiversité que l'on
peut exploiter pour rendre le système
plus résilients et bien évidemment il
faut protéger le microbiote de la plante
ce que le microbiote de la plante tout
comme le microbiote intestinal chez vous
et responsable en grande partie de votre
santé et bien le microbiote de la plante
est responsable de la santé de la plante
donc éviter tous les produits biocides
que ce soit des produits naturels ou
biologique
donc en conclusion simplement partager
cette réflexion c'est de dire serre nos
écosystèmes sont en danger oui
mais l'espoir est devant nous et nous
avons les solutions en fait les
solutions elles sont là sous nos yeux
sous nos pieds il suffit d'observer il
suffit de comprendre et aujourd'hui avec
les moyens de la science moderne avec le
numérique avec l'intelligence
artificielle nous avons les moyens de
comprendre cet écosystème les objets
leurs interactions
oui c'est complexe et la complexité fait
peur mais il faut accueillir cette
complexité avec bienveillance parce que
la complexité des écosystèmes c'est
justement la clé de voûte de la réponse
de nos solutions de demain donc je vous
encourage tous à habran a embrassé la
complexité merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]